I'm Michael shuttin I teach at Columbia
Journalism school I'm a professor there
in the ph.d program and the master's
programs and I'm a historian in
sociology of American politics and media
and I've just published a book called
the rise with the right to know politics
and the culture of transparency 1945 to
1975 the concept of regno since it came
to be part of our language in the 50s
and 60s has transformed a great deal in
American society
with respect to government where the
term is used most frequently it has made
government information more accessible
to the press more accessible to the
public and I should add it makes
executive government of information more
accessible to the Congress itself much
more broadly it changed how people think
about their lives in America it's
changed how doctors talk to or don't
talk to their patients it was common
practice with with a patient who had a
serious probably fatal illness for the
doctor not to tell them that
and there's stunning evidence of this in
some surveys done and one in 1961 that
found that 12% of doctors treating
cancer patients mentioned to the patient
that they had cancer and by 1979 the
survey was repeated and it was 98
percent of doctors and the this this
changed aspects of medical research
where subjects of medical research had
to be informed informed consent to
participate in the research
especially if there was something that
might damage them or affect their health
adversely campaign finance disclosure
came in in the 1970s and people would
share much more than they had before
about again aspects of their own
lives that had been private when Betty
Ford I was diagnosed with breast cancer
in 1974 she spoke about that publicly
and she spoke about her mastectomy
publicly and this was shocking to people
in 1974 but but she became something of
a national hero and as a result the the
right to know is is a not technically
illegal right
that is it's not protected by the
Constitution it is in some specific
instances it's protected by legislation
so if you want information from the
government and you file a Freedom of
Information Act request because it's not
you can't find it on the department's
website or anywhere else and phone calls
don't work so you file a FOIA as it's
called request and the government is
obliged by law to respond to you within
so many days if they respond and they
say we're not going to share it that
information because it they have to
specify it for all - under exemption so
and so you can say well so they tell me
but they're wrong and I'm gonna sue for
this information and then you can take
them to court under the Freedom of
Information Act and you may win and you
may lose but more than a few times you
will win
looking ahead with the internet can we
imagine a case where we're going to cut
back on all this information sharing can
we can we put the genie back in the
bottle not entirely no I don't think we
can and we have to learn to adapt to a
wildly new environment there are a lot
of these dilemmas that are going to keep
arising as we take it for granted that
information is supposed to be public as
a first principle I think yes
public information should be public but
in practice it gets vastly more
complicated in that